Islam by its followers the best examply
Muslim is our beloved Prophet Muhammad s
Ali wasallam best exemp Muslim so sister
some people by looking at Muslims may go
away from Islam some people may come
closer therefore the right way is to
judge the authentic sources and though
the media is against Islam as the sister
rightly said you have people like San
Rashi writing books saic veres those who
have read they know what the book is
about so I say alhamdulillah it's
Allah's will whatever happens happens
for good
alhamdulillah though he sled the prophet
his wife knowah yet there are hundreds
of people who accepted Islam only
because of Salman R these book
alhamdulillah Allah has his ways he can
even let the devil do his
job he has his ways
alhamdulillah so he has his ways how he
does the job many people only became
Muslims because of
salash and those who are away from Islam
maybe it's tend than them that's a
different thing but the amount of you
know people did more research you know
people said he's wrong that said this
that whether it's right or wrong you can
refer to my video cassette I've given
death penalties right or wrong but when
people started having different opinion
and the westerners when they want to
form their own opinion they do research
and when they did research of the Lifest
of the Beloved Prophet alhamdulillah
they accepted Islam you know the Western
world as I said the maximum which they
criticize in Islam is the women's rights
in Islam I've given a talk on women's
rights in Islam modernizing outdated
clarifying them his conception and do
you know
today amongst the westerners more women
are accepting Islam than men if Islam
subjugates the women how come more
Western of women are accepting Islam
than the
men you know why because when they do
research and some people do research for
speaking against
Islam for example Gary Miller you know G
one of the rewards drar he was given the
Quran to take out mistakes and he tried
to take out mistakes he couldn't he
accepted
Islam so there are many people who like
to criticize Islam they read and then
they realize the truth is something else
so different people alhamdulillah Allah
subh gives them hi in different way some
people look at Muslim and they accept
Islam some people do research and accept
Islam some people to attack Islam they
take a step and one of the best
supporters of islamar may Allah be
pleased with him he was one of the
staunchest enemy before our Prophet
prayed that among the two may Allah be
pleased with one of them may Allah let
one accept Islam and alhamdulillah so
the different reasons and different
things many people's problems are solved
regarding D doing the
job I don't think so believe me we
aren't doing our job we as a Muslim we
aren't doing our
job in fact Islam is a religion which is
a missionary religion Allah says in
Surah Al Imran 3:
11 oh Muslims we are the best of people
evolve for
mankind because we enjoy what is good
and we forbid what is wrong and we
believe in Allah Allah calls us the best
of people because we are supposed to
enjoy what is good and forbid what is
wrong and believe in Allah every Muslim
is supposed to be a d if not a full-time
D at least a part-time D how many D do
we have full time in the world you can
count them on your fingertips it's a
shame of the Muslim
um but Allah has given a promise by
which I ended my talk Sur 61:9 Sur 9:33
and Sur fat 48:28 that Islam will
prevail over all the other ways of life
with or without you with or without me
the rabbish that we are Allah doesn't
require you and me to make his Dean
Prevail in the world or in the west the
rubbish that we are Allah doesn't
require us Allah has given G us an
opportunity to do a prophet job and to
earn a prophet's reward make ha as the
sun is shining believe me we are not
doing a
job we Muslims as a whole we should be
people who do maximum dawa but the
Christians you know them 60,000
Christian missionaries Crusaders raising
the dust throughout the world full
time and hundreds of thousand more who
are supporting them how many Muslims do
we have as full-time di how many
it's a shame on us but Allah without
without you without without me Allah
says in the Quran in Surah Muhammad
chapter 47 vers
38 if you do not do the job Allah will
substitute in your place and other
people and they will not be like you you
know we think oh we have got the key to
heaven to J if you don't do the job
Allah will substitute in a place and
other
people and they will not be like you
we think you know Western they are so
bad Allah may make them the to be
tomorrow Allah will substitute you if
you not do the job Allah will substitute
us if you not do the job Allah doesn't
require you and me to do the job the
rubbish that we are he's giving us an
opportunity to do a profit job and to
earn a propit reward so where that is a
concern I would say that we are far
below even the passing level as a um as
a whole we are not doing the job there
are few people alhamd
Al may Allah give them more life and
health but as a whole we have very few
Muslim dies so sister I wouldn't say
that dawa is doing the job Allah is
doing through his own ways through his
thing if if we would follow the Quran
then there would be many more hundreds
and millions of more that's what
required hope that question
uh thank you uh our current speaker for
this very genuine and educative lecture
you have given
us uh my question
is in fact the first part of the
question is already asked by the sister
and you have answered it that is the
role of
Muslims as to the topic as how the
Western are reverting to Islam
I was waiting when you were giving the
roles of the the reasons why they are
reverting to Islam I was waiting for you
to mention that there are also Muslims
who are playing the game but I waited
all in vain and that's why I was coming
here to ask you about the role of
Muslims what are we really doing in
order to make those people rever to
Islam so you have answered that one
maybe and maybe you will shed more light
on it now uh the second part of the
question
is taking the W as
such sometimes for me it becomes very
difficult very hard so much so that
there are some of them there who do not
believe in scriptures they don't have
scriptures manuscript and so on so it
becomes very difficult for me to deal
with such a people to convince them and
make them
revert only very few people of your
caliber maybe can succeed in doing that
so what can we do actually in this field
and on top of
that uh I attended your talk there in
UIA you mentioned that there are also
some in the East that is in India who
have claimed
Divinity uh there are multitude of them
there so those on how can we deal with
them
they don't have the scripture not only
don't have the scripture but again they
are the one to reveal to give us the
scriptures because they are Gods so how
can you convince God to to to to believe
in another God thank
you brother basically three questions
the first one is about dawa that what is
the role of the Muslims in spting Islam
secondly how can you convince those who
don't believe in scriptures talking
about atheists and third those who claim
to be God like in India how can you tell
a god about about the
scriptures the first part I already
answered just addition when I said that
Muslims aren't doing up to the level
that doesn't mean Muslims aren't doing
any job there are Muslim organization in
the Western World they good organization
like isna alhamdulillah they're doing
the job but not what they should not
that that organization Muslim as a whole
what they should be doing they AR doing
not that only westerners should do the
job
Muslims throughout the um should do the
job I'm not only blaming the Muslims in
America Etc Muslim as a whole umah
should do the job so as the umah as a
whole we aren't doing up to the level
which we should do but there are good
organization also I've been to the West
several
times brother you Islam he has a
wonderful school one of the best Islamic
school that I've been to Islamic
foundation in leester is in USA Islamic
Society for North America eiz Islamic
Circle for North America alhamdulillah
there are organizations but not what we
should do up to the level there should
be many more not just a few
handful the second question how can we
convince those people who don't have
scriptures and third is who make
scriptures they don't hands who don't
have scriptures like who don't believe
in God like atheist whether us how can
we convince if a person has scripture
like Bible Christians Hindu vas we can
talk about the scripture how can you
convince any
theist if you were there for my talk
today Afternoon brother I told you the
master key was what Al Imran chapter
number three verse number 64 which
says come to Common terms as between us
and
you the master key for da is come to
Common terms as between us and you so
brother ask that how will we talk to an
atheist are there any common terms
between atheist are any common
terms how will we speak to an ath
when I meet an atheist the first thing I
do is I congratulate
him I congratulate an atheist you may
ask why is brother Zak congratulating an
atheist I congratulate him because he's
a Christian because father is a
Christian that person is Hindu because
father is a Hindu many Muslims are
because fathers are Muslims this atheist
is thinking that is coming from a
religious background maybe a Christian
or a Hindu background if he coming from
Hindu background one God is fighting
with other God the God's wife is taken
away and the god takes 12 years to save
his wife how long will it take to save
me if I'm in problem and God is
crucified on the cross so it starts
thinking how can we believe in such God
so he doesn't believe in God I
congratulate him you know why because he
has said the first part of the Islamic
Shah there is no
God what I have to do is prove to him
ill which I shall do inshallah so half
my job is done with the Hindu and the
Christian first has to tell him the that
your worshiping is wrong and then put
the correct concept of Allah subhana
tala here half my job is done he already
agreed there is no
God so my job is easy so I congratulate
him there's no God but then you should
prove Allah which I shall do inshallah
and there are various techniques showed
in my cassette is the Quran God's word
Quran modern sign how to do it I'll just
tell you in
brief I'll asking the first that suppose
if you have an object a machinary which
which no one in the world has seen if I
tell that atheist it's brought to you
for the first time in front of you this
Machinery this object no one in the
world has seen no one first time it's
Bor in front of you who will be the
first person who will be able to tell
you the mechanism of this object can you
guess who will be the first person who
will be able to tell you the mechanism
of this object can anyone make any
guess the maker any other
guess the Creator the person who makes
this see whatever answer the atheist
give we tell you the maker or the
Creator or the manufacturer or the
producer somewhat similar keep it in
your mind the first person who will tell
you the mechanism of object which no one
has seen in the world is the creator or
maker or the
manufacturer now you ask him how did the
universe come into existence so he will
tell you that today's science has told
us initially there was one primary in
abah then there was secondary separation
there the big band which gave rise to
galaxies planets and the present Earth
we live in talking about the Big Bang
Theory that's how the universe came into
existence so you tell him but this is
already mentioned in the Quran 14400
years ago in 21 verse number 30 which
says do not the unbeliever
see that the Heaven and the Earth were
joined together and we clo them a ther
who could have mentioned about this big
bang the talking about which was
discovered yesterday in science
yesterday mean 30 years back 100 years
back Quran mentions 4 years ago who
could could have mentioned that so he
will tell you you know maybe it's a flow
don't argue with next part you ask him
what was the initial
state of the celestial matter before the
universe was created he will tell you it
is gas you tell him this book the Quran
says in 41 vers number 11 that it was
Duan it was smoke so you ask him is it
right or wrong he will tell you that
smoke is more appropriate than gas if
you know the science well you ask him
what the shape of the Earth he will tell
you this
theorical so you ask when did you
discover this if you know the science
well he will tell you in 1577 s Francis
D was the first person who sailed around
the earth you tell him Quran says inat
79 verse number
30 and thereafter we have made the Earth
egg shaped referring to the Egg of an
ostrich which is not round like a ball
you tell him the Quran says the Earth is
not round like a ball it is Saturn from
the top and bulging from the center he
say yes yes that's more correct it is
geeric you are telling it is round Quran
said is gopher 1400 years ago who could
have mentioned that a a prophet who
wrote the Quran he's the intelligent
person he may say something don't argue
the light of the Moon its own light or
reflected light he will tell you
reflected Quran say in suran 25: 61 I
was Tau in school the sun was stationary
it didn't rotate about access Quran says
inia 21 verse number 33
that is Allah who has created the night
and the day the Sun and the
Moon each one traveling in orbit with
its own motion Quran says the sun
revolves and rotates in school I didn't
learn that I was didn't rotate about
axes it was stationary he will know
latest Discovery in science tells us
that The Sun Also rotates and it takes
about 25 days to complete one notation
who could have mentioned in the
Quran ask him he will pause like that
Quran speaks about biology every living
thing made from water who could have
written that Quran speaks about water
cycle how the water rise Falls form to
clouds clouds move in the interior water
falls down and the water cycle is
completed Quran speaks about salt and
Sweet Water there are two types of water
salt and Sweet Water between there a
barrier which is forbidden to be
trespassed Surah fan 25:53 and 55: 19 to
20 Quran speaks about geology that we
have made the Earth as an
expanseal and the mountain that mistakes
Sur 78: 6 and 7 who could have mentioned
that keep on asking and the only answer
he can give
you it can't be by
FL because the theory of probability you
tell about theory of probability that
the chances that if it's a FL for
example if I toss a
coin the chance is that I'll be right is
one out of two it can either be heads or
tails and if I make a fluk guess the
chance I'll be right is half one upon
two if I toss a coin twice the chances
I'll be right both the time is half into
half is 1 upon four it's
25% if I toss a coin thce chances I'll
be right all three times is 1 upon 2
into 1 upon 2 into 1 upon 2 is 1 upon 8
is 12 and a half% similarly if you use
this probability
Theory to the Quran that what are the
possible shapes a person can think of
for the
earth a person can think of about 30
shapes
it can be square it can be flat it can
be quadrangle it can be rectangle it can
be triangle it can be spherical 30
shapes the chances that someone makes a
wild guess it correct is one out of 30
light of moon can be own light or
reflected light chances someone makes a
guess it's correct is 1 upon two chances
both are correct is 1 upon 30 into 1
upon 2 is 1 upon
60 a person wants to make a guess
everything is created of what in the
desert of Arabia person will first think
of sand
of wood of some other metal aluminium
maybe iron and maybe person can think of
10,000 things which living creatures can
be made of chances that he makes a wild
guess and it's correct is one upon
10,000 chances that all three are
correct is 13 into 1 upon 2 into 1 upon
10,000 is 1 60,000 if you calculate
0017 is
0.17% in three things it has come to
0.17% if you put up all Quran speaks
about thousand verses about Science and
Mathematics tells us if 0 if there are
50 zos it is equivalent to zero the
chances that it's a wild guess is
zero who could have written that he will
tell you Creator maker manufacturer this
Creator we call Allah subhana
tala I just told in short for more
details refer to my video casset is the
Quran God's word various techniques
various techniques to prove the ex of
Allah subh tala third question by the
post is how can you prove to a god that
what is scriptures are wrong Etc in my
talk I gave you a l Miss test for
theology suras chapter number 112 verse
1 to 4 so you tell him that if you are
God do you pass the test suppose someone
says that this is a gold jewelry I want
to sell it to you 24 karat gold what
will you do will you buy it will you buy
it you will say first I'll check up
whether it's true or not you will check
it with touch Stone you'll go to a
Jeweller and say see there's a man who
wants to send me this jewelry and he's
telling it's 24 karat gold you'll go to
a jeweler he will take your jewelry and
rub it against the touch tone and he
match the color if it matches the 24
carat he a 24 Kat if it matches with 22
karat he will say 22 karat if 18 karat
he will tell you 18 karat it may not be
gold at all because All That Glitters Is
Not
Gold so example of rajish which I gave
use rajish for example
he's the almighty God put him to test
of let's put to test that say he's Allah
one and only is r one and only or anyone
any anyone who claims to be God whether
it be Jesus this peace be upon him
whether it be Ram lakman anyone you put
to test normally use HMA I don't use the
main god they feel
insulted like Quran says inam 6 ver 108
revile not Those whom they worship God
besides Allah lest in the ignorance they
will Reve Allah subhana tala so to these
people who say that they are Gods you
check them out with the touch on Sur
class and you can prove that they aren't
God so if they aren't God the scripture
being right is out of the question at
all hope that answer the
question I have a clarification to make
I the Hadith that you mentioned about
marriage being half the dean I just
wanted to know is it getting Mar married
completes half your Dean or the entire
process of marriage how you deal with
marriage how you deal with your husband
or wife the whole marriage right from
you get married to the rest of your life
or just the fact that you got married is
half done sister that's very good
question that the Hadith that marriage
completes half your Dean does it mean
that only marriage completes half your
Dean or the whole process Etc sister as
I mentioned that when the prophet said
marriage completes half your de he meant
that marriage promin you from promis
from fornication from adultery after
that marriage is a full process various
Hadith the Beloved Prophet said that
when you marry you normally look for
four things wealth Beauty nobility and
virtue when you marry people look the
girl is beautiful or the boy is handsome
how wealthy he or she is which family
shik family Sayad family Noble family
and last is virtue Prophet said the most
important of all these four is virtue so
when you get married the whole process
itself you look for a virt ous wife or a
virtuous husband how you get married a
beloved Prophet said the best marriage
is that in which the least expense is
made we have marriage in the Muslim in
many countries they spend hundreds and
thousands of dollars and Rings also
maybe here several they spend
excessively Quran says in is 17: 2526
that if you're a spend thft the brother
of the devil so choosing a life partner
how to get married in Simplicity in
Sunnah all this then how you up bring
your children after marriage be loyal to
your wife not that after marriage for
good and do adultery yet you're
completing half your Dean the prophet
said the best of you is he who's the
best to his wife how you treat your wife
the Quran says in 4: 19 treat your wife
with equity and kindness even if you
dislike her even if you dislike your
wife the Quran says treat her with
equity and kindness people give doy in
the Eastern World in India from the
woman in Islam you have to give my hair
if you get married then you have to be
like a good husband after you get
married you have children you have to be
like a good father or a good mother all
this process in Toto which is related
with marriage if you do all of these
these constitute have the Deen to be a
good mother to be a good father to be a
good husband to be a good wife not to be
extravagant all these process to abstain
from adultery homosexuality promiscuity
all these nearly constitute half the
teachings of Islam therefore beloved
Prophet said marriage completes half
your de means you marry and follow Islam
in all those aspects inshallah half
didn't be
complete
Alum um okay I you were just talking
about the westernness just now right and
I am a convert or revert in your words
um and before I converted I had a very
bad picture about Islam I mean I I sorry
to say I hated Islam and the reason was
because like you said because the
Muslims that I had dealt with I
mean I I feel that since we are talking
about how to you know do the dawa to
non-muslims it's very difficult even for
me to even talk to my family because of
the picture that we portray to them I
think that it's if you're talking about
Islam itself okay fine it's it's very
very good religion it is the only true
religion
but don't you think it's wrong to always
criticize other religions I mean that
approach is like really wrong I mean we
criticize westernness so much should we
do that I
mean whatever you said about about rapes
and all those things it occurs in Muslim
countries I mean Middle Eastern
countries it might not be reported that
much but it goes on so why do we always
pick on them and the other the other
thing is that about women you were
saying that non-muslims say that Islam
sub subjugates women because there are
so many things in the Quran that you
know refers to males and females but
somehow whatever that refers to males is
just ignored and everything that you
know refers to females is press so hard
like you were just saying that virtuous
husband and wife but no I mean I've only
heard it when I've read all the books
it's like you're supposed to get you
know virtuous wife and no I mean
everything is towards to women only so
why do we do that it's very difficult to
convince a non-muslim because we do that
and one more example is you know that I
I was told that rasol Allah had you know
like he gave equal hand in helping his
wife in housework and all those things
but why don't why do we only have books
on how to be a good wife why don't we
ever have lectures or anything on how to
be a good husband you know like nothing
everything is only pressed on women
women are supposed to be doing this
doing that that's not what the religion
says so maybe that's the reason why we
are putting off
non-muslims sister ask a very good
question very relevant she said that
alhamdulillah she's a reort I'd like to
congratulate her alhamdulillah and she
said said that she had a very wrong
picture of Muslims before and I did say
in my talk that many people when they
look at Muslims they would never like to
become a Muslim I said that my talk
alhamdulillah Allah give her hi and she
accepted Islam and she said that the
talk was based on how to talk to the
West the talk was why the West is coming
to Islam it wasn't based on how to Da to
West I've got other cassette dealing
with that I've got a cassette on
misconception about Islam how
specifically to do dawa amongst the West
is a different technique to today my
talk was not how to dawa it was the
reason why West is accepting Islam and
I'm calling a spade a
spade and you said sister very rightly
that you should not criticize other
religion Quran says that in suram 6 ver
108 revile not Those whom they worship
God besides Allah lest in the ignorance
they will Reve Allah subhana tala but
the Quran also says inah is chapter
number 17 verse number 81
82 when truth is in falsehood falsehood
perishes but it nature falsehood is
bound to perish you said that I was
criticizing the Western World and
talking about XY Z sister criticizing
means actually what I would say that
without any proof what I was quoting is
statistics of America so if Americans
want to criticize America and if I'm
quoting them then why are you blaming me
criticizing means what you know actually
what I would say that picking up points
and twisting them like the westerners
do I I'm sorry I'm blaming them again
but that's a
fact I have to call us spade a spade and
the westers love calling us spade a
spade and they proud to call us P SP
they say no we are bold we are truthful
alhamdulillah even I'm truthful it may
not go down the throat that's a
different thing they showed in the media
the women are subjugate Etc and I've
given the talk on that to clarify so
sister what I was doing I was quoting
FBI report written not by Muslims by the
westerners quoting statistics of rape
not by Muslims
by non-muslim westerners about adultery
about incest I'm only quoting their
statistics and when I quote to them they
cannot say Zak is criticizing because
you know why I'm quoting from their
statistics if I say h Mr Ahmed Ali said
this so they'll say okay this is Ping a
faster one I'm not quoting Ahmed Ali or
Sultan B I'm
quoting their statistics so therefore
I'm using my
hikm and besides they saying that even
rape takes place in other countries it's
not reported sister I would like to
disagree with you rape takes more in the
Western Country it's not reported there
you know it is so common rape is so
common it's not worth reporting I've
been to West hardly I read any cases of
rape it is so common it's a day-to-day
life it's not reported sister if it's
reported in news brief if a rape take
place in other countries headlines it
does take not that doesn't take place it
takes place throughout the world least
rap is where you're talking Muslim
countries it does take those Muslim
countries we do not follow the Islamic
law it takes place the least state of
rape is in which country sister which
country least rape in the world it's in
Saudi Arabia least rape it may be taking
place there also I'm not saying it is
nil there are black sheeps in the
community throughout the world but the
least state of rape in any country in
the world it's in Saudi Arabia the least
state of robbery in any country in the
world it's in Saudi Arabia yes there may
be other Muslim countries who don't
follow Islam so they are sud
Muslims regarding reporting if it takes
place in other countries that comes in
headlines because rape is something
which is a stigma in America it's a
lifestyle like as the doctor said if a
patient comes I have a we doctor say I
have so nothing great they they
Shameless according to me they shame
according to them it's fine so sister
when I'm calling a spade a spade I have
to call it I use the best words public
property but that's a fact so people may
say criticize but I have to call a spade
a spade and that's the reason the
westerners like it alhamdulillah so
regarding your first thing that I'm
criticizing them I'm quoting the
statistics like for example Quran
says invite all the way of the Lord with
wisdom and preaching and argue with them
and reason with them in the ways that
are best and most gracious beloved
Prophet said to the
Christians Quran says that when you tell
a Christian do not say trity this say
stop it it's better for you even if if
you say it in the best form he's bound
to feel
hurt see when you take out the fults of
a person the best way you say he's bound
to feel hurt when I tell a Christian why
do you worship Jesus Christ even if I
say his love and care he's bound to feel
hurt so I have to say in the best way
which is acceptable but he bound to feel
hurt not that I'm going out of the way
to insult them I'm giving the
statistics that was regarding a second
part regarding a third part that why do
Muslim Scholars and speakers speak about
wom women only picking up ver of the
women and not talking about what rights
men have to do sister I think you should
see my cassette woman's rights in Islam
and after I give that talk people say
when I going to give a talk man's rights
in
Islam and in that cassette I say what
the husband should do to the wife and
even today if you heard me when I talked
about hijab I made the same statement
which you made that normally Muslim
speakers they speak about hijab for the
woman but Allah speaks first of the
hijab for the man
so why the other people do that you have
to go and ask them I cannot answer on
their behalf so if you want to see a
neutral approach alhamdulillah of Islam
you can hear my video cassettes and
there you'll find even in my women's
rights in Islam I spoken how a husband
should behave to the wife more of that
educating even the men and many men they
don't like it and they say now when will
you give a talk on men's rights in
Islam so sister I have given talks
alhamdulillah Islam believes in equality
between men and women but equality
doesn't mean
identicality men and women are equal but
they aren't identical and if you hear my
talk I've talk about spiritual rights of
the women of social rights I spoken
about economic rights about legal rights
about political rights about educational
rights alhamdulillah and tried to
explain that alhamdulillah Islam
believes in equality between men and
women equality doesn't mean identicality
if you compare to the Western world
again giving statistics quoting what
they believe the Western talk of women's
liberalization is nothing but a
disguised form of exploitation of a body
degradation of honor and depriving her
soul the Western Society claiming to
opli the woman have actually degraded
her to a status of concubine of Mystic
of society butterflies which are mere
tools in the hands of Pleasure Seekers
and sex marketeers which are hidden
behind the colorful screen of art and
culture the Western world to uplift the
woman have actually degraded her it
talks about oh we want to uplift the
woman Etc what are they doing surely
many of you may have gone to the Western
world it's only in the name of art and
culture it's a colorful screen but
behind them you know what's happening
they want to change the role they man
can do this even wom can do this men and
women are equal but they aren't
identical men and women are different in
physiology they're different
biologically for everything the man does
the woman cannot do
everything the woman does the man cannot
do tomorrow you cannot say okay even I
want to give birth to a child I cannot
give I'm
different and do you know in Islam the
stat is I'll just quote a couple of
examples I've given my talk in Islam
where love is concerned and
companionship for the parents our
beloved Prophet said in s bukari volume
number eight in the book of AD chapter
number two Hadith number two once a
person came to the prophet and said who
deserves the maximum love and
companionship in this world
so the prophet said your mother the man
asked who next the prophet said your
mother the man asked after that who the
prophet said for the third time your
mother the man asked after that to the
fourth time the prophet said your father
that means 75% of love and companionship
34 of the love and companionship goes to
the mother the remaining 25% 1/4 of love
and companionship goes to the father in
short mother gets a gold medal mother
gets a silver medal she also gets the
bronze
medal the father has to be satisfied
with the mere consolation
price see these are the teachings of
Islam this is what a prophet taught us I
cannot say oh mother get so much respect
so I also want to give birth to a child
I
can't so men and women as I said are
overall equal but they aren't identical
for example if in a classroom there are
two students A and B both of them get 80
out of 100 both come out first but if
you add analyze the question paper the
question paper has got 10
questions each carrying 10 marks in
answer to question number one student a
gets n out of 10 so student a is n out
of 10 and student b gets seven out of 10
so in question one a has a degree of
advantage that student B in question two
b gets 9 out of 10 a gets s out of 10 so
in question two B has a degree of
advantage in the remaining eight
questions both get eight out of 10 so
overall if you add up both get 80 out of
100 both are
equal but in question number one a has a
degree of Advantage than b in question
two B has the degree of Advantage then a
so men and women are equal but they
antical suppose a robber comes into my
house comes to Rob I cannot say I
believe in women's lip I believe in
equality in women I won't tell my wife
or my sister to go and
fight so Allah says inaha chapter number
four verse number 34
that Allah has given most strength to
the men so men have a degree of
Advantage when it comes to physical
strength so it's he who should protect
the women so in strength men have a
degree of Advantage as I give you
another example in
companionship the mother gets more
respect than father so in some aspects
men have a degree of advantage in some
aspect women have a degree of Advantage
overall men and women are equal as you
rightly said sister if you read the
teaching of Islam they alhamdulillah
very good don't judge Islam by the the
followers if you want to judge judge by
what a beloved Prophet Muhammad
sallallahu Ali wasallam said so what you
should do sister if you said that there
aren't Islamic books Etc talking about
what husband should do Etc inshallah you
do research and you give talks
alhamdulillah I mean insh Allah will
help you and you'll be more effective
because you being a revert and when a
revert speak it has more effect
alhamdulillah so the thing is that
sister I do agree there are black sheeps
in the community what we should do we
should pick up the good points and we
have even good people alhamdulillah old
or more of them are good than bad we
have to set exemplary of the good people
and the best example of beloved Prophet
Muhammad sallallahu Ali wasallam and
inshallah for a more neutral view as you
said that people the speakers when talk
about women women should do this women
should do that IID request you watch my
cassette and then inshallah you will
change hope that answer
question
hello uh uh Zak
I tried to understand earlier actually
um mentioned
about Western
leader are afraid of
Islam you see even uh
during
jilia the leaders of jilia are not
afraid of Islam and this Ison why they
fight Islam they are more afraid that
when they say uh um when they say the
shahada they know that they have to
change I mean most of the leader of the
world cannot accept the change
so uh most probably why the leaders of
the west or any leaders of the world is
afraid to to is accept Islam is because
they cannot accept the change and I
think the biggest change is they have to
step down
and also uh those leader they have
to um in a way give to a better Muslim
although it's in America or anywhere in
the world POS a question that why should
the Western leader be afraid of Islam
and the leaders of jahia they weren't
afraid of Islam I'm sorry brother I
failed to disagree with you I'm sorry I
disagree with you the
leaders of the Pagan leader the time of
the prophet they were really afraid of
Islam the only thing they were afraid of
was Islam therefore they told the
prophet that we will make you the king
of Arabia if you give up this message of
monotheism we will make you the richest
man in the world the prophet gave the
reply even if you play the sun in my
right hand and the Moon in my left I
will not give up this message of Islam
the leaders were afraid you know why
were they afraid that they had 330 Gods
which they'll have to barter for one God
who will come to Mecca
who come to Mecca and buy all these
other things in which they fell in the
name of idol worship leaders were very
scared later on alhamdulillah Truth had
to Prevail They didn't accept Islam
therefore the Quran says Target the
leaders of kufar Quran says Target the
leaders of kufar Target them if they
accept thousands will follow so
therefore I said most of the leaders of
Western world are afraid not all we have
good people also speaking good things
about his Islam some leaders like Prince
Charles said some few good words his Nia
Allah knows best I don't doubt anyone's
ni some minister of of UK now spoke some
good things about
Islam so brother as I said the leaders
afraid you know why you said it's so
easy they have to accept Islam it is not
that easy brother easy from our point of
view from their point of view difficult
why if they accept Islam who will fill
their
coffers you understand that if the
leaders of
at that time sufyan I mean the other
leaders they were Rich they were the
richest man if they accept Islam who
will bow down to them because in Islam
all the human beings are
equal he will have to embrace the slave
they have to change his lifestyle they
were afraid they have to change their
lifestyle similarly here if they accept
Islam all the human beings are like one
Brotherhood alhamdulillah the leers are
afraid that they will have to come down
from their status in which they're
living in an ivory Tower leaders afraid
that they'll have to give all these
things just to B for Islam but finally
when Allah gives they prefer having a
mansion in the than I mentioned here as
the best example I can give you again is
of a lady Quran says of AIA may Allah be
pleased with her it's mentioned Surah
chapter number 66 verse number 11 that
she prayed to Allah subhana wa ta'ala
that please make a mansion for myself in
the Jenna in exchange for the luxury in
this world she was the wife of the most
powerful supposed to be most powerful
man in the world Pharaoh but yes she
praised to Allah subhana wa ta'ala I
would like to bter all these riches etc
for a mansion in the in the J so alhamd
when Allah gives let him be the biggest
leader he accept Islam for the hope to
answer the question um coming back to
the equality of men and women in Islam
we are told in the Quran of course that
men and women are equal in the sight of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala and that is also
um I mean the rights of wom are backed
up by the Hadith of the Prophet where
the mother is much more important than
the father in terms of respect but then
in the AKA
ceremonies you're required to just
Slaughter one goat for the daughter and
two for the son somewhat indicating that
the sun is more important this is the
question that why during akika are two
goat slaughtered for the Sun and one
goat for the daughter sister there are
several s had saying that you can even
Slaughter one goat for your son it's not
compulsory that's say one goat for
daughter and Two Goats for the son you
can Slaughter even one goat for the son
it's not that you should Slaughter Two
Goats for the son but what I can think
of the reason is that because man in
Islam is the bread earner man in Islam
is a brother no that before woman is
married it's the duty of the father or
the
and after she's married it's the duty of
the husband and the son to look after
her lodging boarding clothing and all
Financial aspect so here alhamdulillah
she is free from Financial Obligations
she's overprotected alhamdulillah so but
natur according to my logic I'm not
saying this is the reason allaham Allah
knows the best reason why two goats for
for a son but that's not only the case
maybe because he's financially more
strong therefore a person is required to
spend more money because of a son that
may be one of the reason Allah knows the
best but compulsory two gos for one son
is not had gives you the option either
one or two and for the woman one no
problem if you wish if you want to sort
more Allah subh T and A beloved Prophet
gave you the option hope
question Asam
Alum doctor just you
mentioned that in the early days it it
was stated that
we should
Target the kufar the leaders of the
kufar
alhamdulillah thee present state of
Muslim
umah as far as the quantity is
concerned almost every fourth uh person
in this world is a
Muslim and every third
country is a Muslim
country
so what I
feel that
presently what we
lack is the leadership of the Muslim
umah am I right to say that we should
Target the leaders of the
different
states the brother asked a good question
that alhamdulillah Islam has spread
throughout the world and according to
him 25% are Muslims every fourth person
and every third country is a Muslim
country but we lack leadership shouldn't
we have a Muslim leader and Target the
leader of the Muslim country I do agree
with you brother you should even Target
the kufar but I do agree with you that
you should have a leader Islam believes
in leadership Islam believes in Amir
unfortunately thefa was abolished last
it was in Turkey by the West n
again it should be reformed that KFA
should be there Islam believes inaa and
we should have
aifa there are groups which are driving
the level best to again have the system
ofat may Allah subhana tala give them
strength and and they are doing their
job there are people who are trying to
convince leaders of various countries
especially the Muslim countries and they
are trying the level best and we pray
that may Allah subhana ta'ala
let a leader emerge amongst the Muslim
umah so that he can guide with the
leader alhamdulillah you can do wonders
so Islam is for leaders so I do agree we
should try and find a good leader who
follows the Quran and the Sunnah
unfortunately most of the today's
political leaders of the Muslim
countries most of them they don't fit
the criteria of the Quran and the Sunnah
so people are trying who will be the
best inshallah may Allah help a leader
to emerge but simultaneously while they
finding leaders of the Muslim um and
When leaders try to emerge the
non-muslims try and put them down they
are trying their way so we should try
and find a leader simultaneously even
follow the other gu of the Quran that we
should Target the kufar so boat should
be done simultaneously and I do agree
with you that there should be a leader
among the Muslim
Community thank you very much for your
patience and your
cooporation uh and
your um time spent here and U our most
uh utmost thanks is to Dr Zak for
enlighting uh us
again and and reaching our knowledge on
Islam and also teaching us on what to do
and trying to spread Islam um shall we
first give him a round of applause in
our usual way of thanking
[Applause]
shall we end the evening with